monsieur pouillard bienvenu merci de
répondre à nos questions alors quels
sont les enjeux pour l om pour ces
élections municipales merci d'abord de
votre invitation
les enjeux bien évidemment ils sont un
peu plus complexes lorsque une formation
politique n'en n'est pas une en fait le
parti politique n'est pas constituée en
tant que tel depuis 2010 est c'est une
gelée dire presqu'une une nuance ou deux
de trop deux ans et demi de d'activité
parlementaires et de réformes
c'est vrai que les élections municipales
se présente comme le premier après les
élections européennes
en fait la première élection
intermédiaire après les élections
législatives de 2010 est c'est vrai que
l'on dit généralement que la première
élection intermédiaire
elle est perdue par l'exécutif eux
entraînés les suivantes c'est à dire les
départementales et les régionales
ça a été le cas lors des deux dernier
quinquennat celui de nicolas sarkozy
celui de françois hollande les
municipales de 2008 ont entraîné
immédiatement un vote identique au cil
d'opposition en 2010 2011 est
naturellement l'alternance s'est faite
en 2012
le quinquennat de françois hollande a
connu exactement le même processus 2014
a entraîné également les départementales
et régionales dans une une chute - moins
terrible que pour les municipales en
tout cas mais en tout état de cause a
devancé l'alternance si l'on peut parler
d'alternance en 2017
est ce qu'on peut dire on a un climat
politique plutôt détériorées depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des manuels mapon
c'est une séquence inédite dans notre
histoire de la vème république
quand je dis une histoire inédite c'est
une histoire inédite pour les élections
pour bien sûr mais pour la pratique de
la gouvernance
nous n'étions pas habitués à des
agressions en quelque sorte vers balader
à une sorte de retour effectivement au
bonapartisme qui est qui apparaît comme
insupportable pour les représentants de
la nation puisque le mouvement
atteint tant l'opposition que aussi
quelques rangs de la république en
marche
donc il y à un état de crispation que
nous n'avons pas connu où il faudrait
remonter pratiquement aux années
pompidou et les débuts de la vème
république pour connaître cette
crispation par rapport un bonapartisme
rampant on à la crise des jd jo non à
cette réforme des retraites très décriée
notamment dans la rue l'utilisation de
49,3 qui plane un peu est ce que
aujourd'hui lrm pourrait être confronté
à un vote sanction dans les urnes lors
des prochaines municipales
alors le vote sanction je venais d'en
parler oui il peut y avoir un vote
sanction avec comment parler dans votre
sanction quand il n'ya pas de sortant
affiché en tout cas république en marche
c'est bien difficile c'est pour ça que
je vous parlais tout à l'heure et des
nuances
il va falloir
clarifier tout ça et vous verrez sans
doute que dans le lin dès le lundi qui
suit le premier dimanche électoral le
premier tour des élections
on y verra peut-être un peu plus clair
dans l'ére composition des listes pour
le second tour
les municipales dans leur histoire ont
toujours montré qu' il fallait être très
prudent en lors de l' annonce des
grandes vagues du premier tour parce
qu'il y avait un un retour de tendance
généralement au deuxième tour et les
municipales ce n'est pas comme les
législatives ce n'est pas un scrutin
majoritaire c'est un scrutin
proportionnel majoritaire de gestion
mais un scrutin proportionnel quand même
et donc on peut mesurer à partir de ce
moment là non pas l'opposition
mais au niveau local les tendances qui
peuvent se présenter vous parliez des
filets jaunes c'est vrai que dans la
composition des listes aujourd'hui qui
vont se présenter il y à une
recrudescence des petites listes que
l'on appelle les listes citoyenne et qui
pourrait effectivement se rapprocher de
l'idée des ronds-points et des gilets
jaunes qui manifestent depuis deux ans
je ne crois pas personnellement en tout
cas il y ait un danger dans la notion de
majorité de scrutin proportionnelle
majoritaire de gestion dans les futurs
conseils municipaux par la présence de
ces listes
faut-il qu'elle franchisse d'ailleurs le
seuil d'admissibilité pour le second
tour donc en revanche on pourra
s'interroger effectivement sur la montée
en puissance des écologistes qui dans
certaines compositions vénétie pas le
temps à gauche qu'à droite vont avoir un
rôle important voire peut-être un un
état dans l'état
si je puis dire et imposer quelques
idées à des mères qui n'en avait pas
voulu au départ monsieur pouillard merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci pour vos
réponses je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de l'observatoire de la vie
politique et parlementaire merci